La statue de la Liberté rentrerait dans ce hangar,
pour vous donner une idée de la taille de la fusée Falcon Heavy.
CA : Et le fait qu'il y a 27 moteurs.
Cela fait partie de la conception,
plutôt que d'inventer de plus grosses fusées,
vous les associez.
GS : C’est cette capacité résiduelle.
Nous avons développé le moteur Merlin pour le lanceur de Falcon 1.
Nous aurions pu jeter ce moteur
et construire un tout nouveau moteur pour le Falcon 9.
Il aurait été appelé autrement,
mais le Falcon 9 a neuf moteurs Merlin,
au lieu de dépenser un milliard de dollars sur un nouveau moteur,
nous en avons assemblé neuf à l'arrière du Falcon 9.
Capacité résiduelle : coller trois Falcon 9 ensemble
et vous avez la plus grande fusée opérationnelle volante.
Cela a été cher à réaliser,
mais c'était un chemin bien plus efficace que de repartir de zéro.
CA : Le BFR est l'équivalence de combien de fois cela
en termes de puissance ?
GS : Le BFR fait environ deux fois et demi cette taille.
CA : Cela vous permet --
je ne crois toujours pas cette vidéo que nous allons passer.
Qu’est-ce que c'est ?
GS : C’est actuellement au sol
mais c’est la navigation spatiale pour les terriens.
J’ai hâte de voir cette capacité résiduelle.
Nous allons faire voler le BFR comme un avion
et voyager d'un endroit à un autre sur Terre.
Vous pouvez décoller de New York ou de Vancouver
et aller à l'autre bout du monde.
Vous ne serez dans le BFR qu'environ une demi-heure ou 40 minutes
et le plus long -- c'est génial.
(Applaudissements)
Et le plus long dans ce vol
est de prendre le bateau pour y aller et en revenir.
(Rires)
CA : Gwynne, enfin, c'est génial, mais c'est fou, non ?
Cela ne va jamais arriver.
GS : Cela va arriver, assurément.
Cela va arriver, assurément.
CA : Comment ?
(Applaudissements)
D’abord, les pays vont accepter ce missile en approche…
(Rires)
GS : Chris, pouvez-vous nous imaginer convaincant le gouvernement fédéral,
les bases aériennes d'accueillir les arrivants ?
Nous le faisons régulièrement.
Nous ramenons le premier étage
et le faisons atterrir sur une base aérienne fédérale.
Nous pourrions le faire
à 10 kilomètres d'une ville, peut-être cinq kilomètres d'une ville.
CA : Combien de passagers peuvent se payer le luxe
de voyager dans l'espace ?
GS : Le premier BFR aura environ une centaine de passagers.
Parlons un peu du côté commercial.
Tout le monde pense que les fusées sont chères
et elles le sont.
Comment rivaliser avec les prix des compagnies aériennes ?
Si vous y réfléchissez, si je peux faire le voyage
en entre une demi-heure et une heure,
je peux en faire des dizaines par jour.
Un avion long-courrier ne peut réaliser qu'un de ces vols par jour.
Même si ma fusée était un peu plus chère
et que le carburant est un peu plus cher,
je peux voler au moins 10 fois plus qu'eux par jour
et tirer les revenus nécessaires de ce système.
CA : Vous croyez vraiment que cela sera mis en œuvre
à un moment de notre avenir. Quand ?
GS : Dans moins de 10 ans, c'est sûr.
CA : Est-ce en temps de Gwynne ou en temps d'Elon ?
GS : C'est en temps de Gwynne. Elon veut que nous allions plus vite.
(Rires)
CA : C’est extraordinaire.
GS : Je suis personnellement investie car je voyage beaucoup
et je n’aime pas voyager.
J’adorerais pouvoir voir mes clients à Riyad,
partir le matin et être de retour à temps pour le dîner.
CA : Nous allons évaluer cela.
En moins de 10 ans, un billet au prix de la classe économique
ou environ 2 000 dollars par personne pour voler de New York à Shanghai.
GS : Le prix sera entre les classes économique et affaires,
mais ce sera en une heure.
CA : Eh bien, c'est quelque chose.
(Rires)
Pendant ce temps, l’autre utilisation du BFR est en développement
pour aller un peu plus loin que Shanghai.
Parlez-en.
Vous avez brossé un tableau assez détaillé
de comment les humains pourraient voler jusqu'à Mars
et ce à quoi cela ressemblerait.
GS : Nous avons une vidéo, une vidéo recadrée
issue de celles que nous avons montrées et quelques nouveaux bouts.
Vous allez décoller d'une plateforme,
vous avez un propulseur et le BFS, le Big Falcon Spaceship.
Ils vont décoller.
Le propulseur va amener le vaisseau en orbite,
en orbite terrestre basse,
puis revenir comme nous le faisons avec les propulseurs.
Cela semble incroyable mais nous travaillons sur les pièces
et vous nous voyez obtenir ces pièces.
Le propulseur revient.
Ce qui est nouveau
est que nous allons le faire atterrir sur la plateforme de lancement.
Actuellement, l’atterrissage se fait sur une plateforme séparée ou un bateau.
Une connexion rapide.
Vous prenez un cargo plein de carburant
ou un dépôt de carburant,
le liez à ce propulseur, l’envoyez en orbite,
faites une manœuvre d’accostage, réapprovisionnez le vaisseau
et partez pour votre destination.
Ici, c'est Mars.
CA : Une centaine de personnes vont sur Mars à chaque voyage
en combien, six mois ? Deux mois ?
GS : Cela dépend de la taille de la fusée.
La première version, et nous continuerons à créer
des BFR plus grands,
c’est un voyage de trois mois.
La moyenne est entre six et huit,
mais nous essayons de faire plus rapide.
CA : Quand croyez-vous que SpaceX fera atterrir son premier homme sur Mars ?
GS : C’est une échelle similaire au voyage de point à point.
C’est la même capacité.
Ce sera d'ici une décennie — pas cette décennie.
CA : En temps réel, à nouveau, d'ici 10 ans.
Ce serait extraordinaire.
(Rires)
Pourquoi ? Sérieusement, pourquoi ?
Vous avez une entreprise dont c’est la mission officielle.
Tout le monde a-t-il adhéré à cette mission,
étant donné que beaucoup de gens
pensent que vous avez tant de talent,
tant de capacité technologique.
Il y a tant de choses à faire sur Terre avec un besoin urgent d'attention.
Pourquoi ce voyage, cette fuite vers une autre planète ?
(Applaudissements)
GS : Je suis ravie de votre question
mais je crois que nous devons ouvrir notre esprit.
Il y a plein de choses à faire sur Terre,
mais beaucoup d'entreprises y travaillent.
Nous travaillons sur l'une des choses les plus importantes possibles :
trouver un autre endroit
pour que les humains vivent, survivent et s'épanouissent.
Si quelque chose se passait sur Terre,
nous avons besoin d'humains vivant ailleurs.
(Applaudissements)
C’est la réduction des risques pour l’espèce humaine.
Cela n’est pas pour contourner
le fait d’améliorer l’état de notre planète
et d’en prendre plus soin,
mais vous devez avoir plusieurs chances de survie,
c’en est une.
Ne parlons pas de ce qui est déprimant,
vous allez sur Mars pour vous assurer que les terriens ne meurent pas.
C’est horrible, c'est une très mauvaise raison de le faire.
Fondamentalement, c'est un autre endroit à explorer
et c’est ce qui différencie les humains des animaux,
notre sens de l’exploration et de l’émerveillement,
de l’apprentissage.
Je dois donc dire,
c’est la première étape pour aller vers d’autres systèmes solaires
voire d’autres galaxies,
et c’est la seule fois où mon idée dépasse celle d'Elon.
Je veux rencontrer des gens dans d'autres systèmes solaires.
Mars, c’est bien, mais nécessite des rénovations.
Il y a du travail pour la rendre habitable.
(Rires)
Je veux trouver des gens, quel que soit le nom qu’ils se donnent,
dans un autre système solaire.
CA : C'est une grande vision.
Gwynne Shotwell, merci.
Vous avez l’un des emplois les plus géniaux sur Terre.
GS : Merci beaucoup. Merci Chris.